[Musique]
cette scène n'a pas été tourné à paris
mais bien au studio mel's à montréal
grâce à la même technologie que celle
utilisée pour le populaire jeu vidéo pac
man en amène avec lui nous enfin les
technologies de jeux vidéo pour créer
une petite révolution un virage
technologique pour marier la technologie
avec la création du contenu
cette petite révolution s'appelle la
production virtuelle
le décor est planté sur cet immense
écran et avec l'aide d'un moteur de jeu
vidéo
quatorze capteurs suivre l'action pour
créer l'illusion parfaite
on pourrait dire que c'est un décor et
tiges puis qui comprend qui comprend la
caméra dans son environnement aussi à
tout moment faire comme un gps
on sait exactement où est ce que la
caméra est donc quand la caméra bouge le
décor virtuel suis exactement une caméra
physique en mode virtuel les
possibilités sont à peu près 1 finit
derrière moi c'est un décor qui était
créée par une équipe d'infographiste
mais en un claquement de doigts je peux
me retrouver à new york avec une ville
des passants beaucoup de bruit sans même
avoir quitté le confort du studio la
série de disney le mandalorien a été
réalisée en californie en grande partie
en production virtuelle mort et elle
veut s'en inspirer l'utilisation des
moteurs de jeux vidéos qui sont devenus
très puissant avec les ordinateurs aussi
qu'il gagne en puissance nous permet de
tourner en direct qu'on appelle en temps
réel les effets visuels directement à
l'écran plutôt que de les ajouter en
post-production la production virtuelle
peut créer l'illusion parfaite mais ça
ne veut pas dire que l'écran vert pour
les effets spéciaux est sur le point de
mourir
je pense que l'écran vert quand même
encore un couple de turda sont dans son
sac
les écrans virtuels ont des limitations
niveaux 2d grosseur des pixels de la
halle de la lumière que ça prend de
l'ampleur que ça va prendre plus
écologique parfois plus économique est
idéal pour la distanciation sociale la
production virtuelle est promise à un
bel avenir selon le fonds des médias du
canada
c'était de production virtuelle arrive à
point nommé
donc beaucoup moins de déplacements des
équipes d'acteurs beaucoup moins de
monde sur les lieux du tournage la
production virtuelle en est encore à ses
débuts mais montréal veut devenir un
chef de file en la matière un dossier à
suivre ici louis philippe ouimet radio
canada bon rien